I've gotten questions from kids after
I've shown them the trailer so they have
some burning questions for you Aurra
who's - wants to know do dolphins fly of
course they do Sam who's 10 wants to
know how did Moana become friends with
the ocean Moana has always felt a really
special connection with the ocean
although her parents and the people on
our Island made it very clear that it's
not something that we do we don't
journey out that curiosity really builds
up inside of her and the ocean remembers
that but Moana has always loved it like
that and that's how they become friends
Ellis who's four wants to know why
Maui do you have so many tattoos on you
because Maui is very proud of his
culture and in Polynesian culture
tattooing is a rite of passage so it's
embraced so that's why Maui has a lot of
tattoos and the tattoos on Maui's body
tells a great story much like the same
tattoos that I have are the same that
Maui has it tells a great story
all right well Ora who's two and a half
she wants to know how do you do moves is
it Ora Ora that's a beautiful name let's
start with that moves are just they're
there they're not easy very challenging
and but Ora I'm sure she if she doesn't
know this she will understand this she
does most - we all do moves so Olivia
who's nine asked how did you compose the
music choose the instruments and that
sound oh that's a great question Olivia
the the answer is the Pacific Islands
did most of the work we're trying to
represent this part of the world that
never gets seen on screen as accurately
as possible so the instrumentation is
log drums and and guitar and and all of
the instruments from those Islands
Vivian who's four asks why does the
chicken like to
so much the same as hey hey hey and he
is he is limited but there was more -
hey hey that's the eye and I think there
was joy in the movie he's probably the
he's one of the funnier things
last question what song do you find
yourself singing in a shower from this
movie
it sounds so egotistical but it's my
song it's you're welcome
you're welcome and we know the way kind
of are always vying for the number one
spot in the playlist don't make me
choose
I I think you're welcome a lot which is
actually Duane song a Maui song but it's
so catchy I guess it's just my way of
being me